hey youtubers what's up this is gonna be
my Constantine episode 9 video I know a
lot of you have questions about when the
series is gonna end and whether or not
it's canceled so I'll try and answer
those two this is really part two of the
mid-season finale so they're wrapping
that up and explaining what the final
arc is going to be episode 13 is gonna
be the last episode and then they'll
decide whether or not to cancel it or
renew it for season two so officially
NBC is still on the fence it's not
cancelled yet so don't worry I'll talk
more about ratings and advertising in
the up front and how I think that's
going to influence whether or not it
gets a season two at the end of this cuz
it gets a little more technical so just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
top five moments number five Constantine
lets the demon inside so surprise
surprise turns out it's not just any
demon
his name is Pazuzu or its name I guess
demons really quite I don't have a
gender instead of being a demon he is
like the king of the demons which is
probably why he scared the invoke day
off their special effects budget isn't
is it real crazy so I think it was
really effective of them to do the smash
cuts where he just he wakes up after
having ripped a bunch of people's limbs
off if it were 150 million dollar movie
you would actually see him ripping
people's arms off and throwing them all
over the place it did seem like it was a
little easy for them to get rid of him
at the end of the episode if he's the
king of demons arguably you think they'd
have to kill Constantine and then the
rest of the story the rest of the season
would be his journey out of hell a lot
of the relationships in the episode did
a 180 from start to finish so like you
start out with Manny who finds out the
Constantine is what the demon in and it
actually seems like he's warm at the
Constantine didn't ask for heaven's help
it's not that I can't help you it's that
I won't pouty angels
howdy cloud hugging angels I like that
insult cloud huggers a lot of
Constantine like a lot of the humor
arises from people insulting each other
like friendly maybe not so friendly
sometimes cuz Annie wasn't so friendly
with Constantine for most of the episode
selfish wanker cloud huggers just added
to the list of Constantine insults
number four Zed escapes the resurrection
crusade I'm really interested to see
where they're gonna take this
resurrection crusade plotline and how
it's gonna dub tail with the Brujeria
right now it seems like the Brujeria in
the resurrection crusade might end up
being the same thing in the comics that
was a little bit different like during
said storyline in the Hellblazer comics
her father was part of a group that was
trying to bring about the
erection of Christ but they're super
crazy so they're like a really sinister
good group the Brujeria on the other
hand are all about chaos so it seems
like they're a different force but just
to simplify things on the TV show they
might marry those two ideas together
that remains to be seen
for now all assume that there are two
separate groups just because the the
Brujeria the man that was walking around
that turned into snakes that do they
killed him he didn't seem like he had a
cross on like he wasn't dressed like the
resurrection crusade member I am
expecting them to resolve that plot by
the finale though I think they were
planning on creating a finale that
worked whether or not they got a season
two or not so I do think that they'll
pay that off usually that's the biggest
complaints at the end of seasons like
when they don't pay off big plots as
they very clearly been teasing and this
one just happens to be about Zed's past
number three Constantine keeps waking up
right after he's killed a whole bunch of
people I feel like it would have been
disingenuous if Constantine had not done
some crazy stuff while I was possessed
by the demon they said that there was a
window there was like an incubation
period but I think they unexpectedly
sped that up because he was the king of
demons the characters didn't understand
which demon was inside of him otherwise
I think it would have been a little
easier for him to control his actions
like he wouldn't have blacked out and
ripped a bunch of limbs off of people it
would have been nicer if they to spend a
little bit more money on blood effects
just like you just see blood flying all
over the place that feels like a very
frank miller type scene like in the Sin
City movies where you just see blood
splatters all over the place
number two we finally have a face for
the Brujeria so this person here works
with the Brujeria but technically he's
not a person so I don't think he's one
of the warlocks and that that's who the
Brujeria are they're basically like a
group of warlocks he's more like a demon
that they raised to help them and even
though they stabbed him at the end I
don't think he's gone forever
he's not a big bad though he's he's not
like the biggest villain of the season
he's just one of the minions at some
point we have to meet the actual
bravuria like the actual group of people
and the resurrection crusade does it
probably happen in the same episode
based on the number of episodes we have
left I mean we have 10 11 12 and then 13
13s in the finale
so I'll probably add some more faces
attached to both those groups by at
least episode 11 I would think you don't
want to spend like all of your finales
setting up who the characters are like
you already want to know who they are
going into it so you can spend the whole
time in the action of the story like
you'd have to spend all that time
explaining and
my number-one moment Annie performs the
exorcism it feels like it's supposed to
be a nexus of spiritual energy so if you
were gonna do anything magical doing it
in that place would probably be the best
way to go whether you were doing
something bad or doing something good
that's what I like about the idea of
magic is it's fairly neutral you can use
it for good you can use it for bad it's
not inherently one of the other and
Marie was performing a traditional
Catholic exorcism though so arguably
that was an act of good if you were
confused about why she couldn't have
just done that before I think it has to
do very specifically with the location
they performed the exorcism the funny
thing is is there's like there's like a
whole other host of magical items that
they probably could have used to help
Constantine if Anne Marie really wanted
to take one for the team and felt like
she couldn't do it she could have just
put the helmet of fate on of course then
she would have been bouncing Naboo like
the helmet ply would have never let her
take it off the last time I saw the
helmet used in a Constantine story was
actually during the new 52 comics and
the show is mostly based on the
Hellblazer comics so I'm actually not
expecting someone to use that before the
finale if anything I'd really like to
see swampthing show up like some sort of
Swamp Thing Easter Egg that that would
be crazy but I don't know that DC Comics
or Warner Brothers would let the show do
that usually things like that using big
characters like that requires some
serious clearance this wasn't really a
story that necessitated that though so I
understand like why they didn't just
like deus ex mashing up bring in some
crazy comic book character to fix all
their problems
there were a whole lot other great
things in this episode you know I did
like the Constantine spent so much of it
reflecting on his true purpose like what
he was trying to do like he really got
real with all the characters this is
what I'm really trying to do I'm kind of
scared I'm not ready to die yet he was
preparing himself for Hell like he was
totally ready for it in his head it
feels like the show in a meta way is
doing the same thing like it's preparing
to get sent to development hell after
season 1 is over if it doesn't get
renewed so you did my big question for
you guys what was your favorite moment
from the episode and if they have to
wrap things up like if they only have
these 13 episodes and that's the series
finale how would you want them to go out
I mean they've kind of already shot the
episode but if there's anything you're
hoping to see in the finale let me know
what it is so it's part of like some of
the small changes that I'm trying to
make the videos instead of just giving a
flat-out rating I'm just gonna do like
my thumbs down sometimes I'll have five
sometimes there's really just like three
or four really big things that I felt
could have been done better starting
with first
thumbs-down so during the exorcism at
the end I didn't really buy into Annie's
doubt it was all about the demon trying
to get her to doubt herself so she
wouldn't be able to do the exorcism I
just I didn't buy that she didn't
believe in herself it was just that the
performance itself the actors
performance next thumbs down
so Efrain Ramirez from Napoleon Dynamite
I felt like he was a little overcast for
the role the character was meant to be
like this Morgan Freeman Shawshank
character who just who was very
connected could get anything you want
inside the prison but was somewhat
sympathetic there might have been some
scenes of his that got left on the
cutting room floor but I just I didn't
feel like they developed the character
enough and thus all I could think about
was Napoleon Dynamite he's done a lot of
different stuff I mean Napoleon Dynamite
was a long time ago but anytime he shows
up that's all I can think about
so next thumbs down I feel like the
prison scenes would have worked better
at night daylight is not the show's
friend there's like a number of
technical reasons why shooting at night
is better - it just allows you to work
around smaller budgets so like sometimes
when your budget is smaller you don't
have the money for a lot of extras or
really extravagant sets and when you
turn the lights down it just makes
people focus on those things less I
would really like to see them get a
little more comic book II with the
cinematography Gotham is a really good
example of a show that does some
ridiculous things or you know gets a
little silly sometimes but totally
embraces it with the cinematography to
be fair though you know just to be fair
not to be too hard on Constantine Gotham
might have a bigger budget for CG gloomy
clouds I'm totally into Dutch angles and
really weird you know comic book II
shots when they fit with the tone of the
show and I feel like at times you know
it'd be totally appropriate for
Constantine to do that it's just that
sometimes the atmosphere on the show
feels like it doesn't match the
narrative so I feel like it would have
been more effective if they had moved
from date tonight at the end of the
episode instead of doing the reverse so
next thumbs down I feel like they need
to get a little more comfortable with
the use of silence Constantine as a
character is a very talky dialogue heavy
character but sometimes it's even more
effective when characters don't talk and
they use their body language to
communicate a really good example of
this is Stephen Amell on arrow he's
someone that does a great job of
communicating with hard stairs but
during the prison scenes whatever he was
trying to intimidate other characters I
feel like he didn't need to yell at them
like he could have just stared with
these crazy red eyes so next week is an
episode I always have to check I always
get in trouble when I'm like yep next
new episode next week and it turns out
like the State of the Union address
reschedule is it so but yes Constantine
episode 10 will air January 23rd and
remember now it's at 8 p.m. Eastern Time
so it's a couple hours earlier than it
normally was so hopefully that'll help
their ratings a little bit just to talk
a little bit more about ratings in
season 2 honestly I think the ratings
that they're getting right now are
actually pretty decent it's hard to tell
what NBC considers good because arrow
for instance is actually rated similarly
like Constantine is doing pretty well in
terms of CW shows but what the CW
considers good ratings and what a major
network considers good ratings are very
very different and a lot of it depends
on the advertising they can sell like if
advertisers don't care about Constantine
and they don't want to buy ads while
Constantine is on the air then it's much
more likely that they would cancel the
show it sounds weird but that's just the
broadcast model for making shows like
this isn't a cable network isn't it's
not like HBO where the revenues are
based on subscriptions I know people
always get upset about ads but like
YouTube for instance is supported by ads
so that's like that's why you don't see
me going around begging for money I am
very hopeful I think if we could stay
solid or you know maybe even if it's
ratings can increase just a little bit
then we'll see a short season to like
they'll just do another 13 episodes
which I'm totally happy with Marvel's
agent Carter is only doing eight
episodes and they're totally happy with
that so I think people are getting used
to shorter runs it's okay if a show does
not do 23 episodes so in related news
I'm actually I'm working on a new visual
style for the videos that I do so
hopefully I'll be able to test that out
and the Star Wars and the Game of
Thrones videos that I'm working on well
you guys be able to give me some
feedback I'm just trying to make it look
a little more comic book II because a
lot of the stuff I do is John Rose stuff
so it's either based on comic books or
it has something to do with comic books
so I just I feel like that'd be a little
bit more fun to try out
Star Wars coming next I'm gonna be doing
videos for the comic books for the new
Star Wars comic books and then Game of
Thrones well you guys wait for all those
of the videos you can click here to
catch up on Constantine and you can
click here for the latest trailer for
arrow to learn about season two of the
flash season 4 of arrow so lots of stuff
happening here on the flash coming next
week so get ready for that thank you so
much for watching so let's all high-five
I will see you guys tonight
you